tout cela vous de la série à
bonsoir à tous et ne touche pas ma deux
là c'est pas l'animateur qui en parle
c'est le danseur
[Musique]
bon
après cette petite démonstration je peux
reprendre mon costume d'animateur eu
juste nathalie marqué que je vous ai
fait avec jean pierre pernaut pour la
saint valentin
mais je suis préparé un petit déjeuner
ouais et ensuite tant que je vais
déposer sur son lit ouais et après j'ai
remis la musique du sperme du savoir
faire fait seule la géographie de star a
dû oui j'ai fait le style un strip tease
de star alliance
oui moi devant jean pierre pernaut oui
devant larry j'avais envie de refaire la
piste surprise non et là il a dit je
reproche juste être un oui c'est une
nouvelle épidémie c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est conseil scientifique qui le
dit c'est au ministre qu'il le dit ça a
été exactement dix ans était enfin riant
c'est un nouveau c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est les autorités publiques
glissait beaucoup d'elles mêmes mais
beaucoup amusé en disant on va
maintenant merde si même le conseil
scientifique cm2 les rêveurs out on n'a
pas fini je vais faire quoi moi pas
d'accord avec ça j'arrive moi c'est pas
moi c'est le conseil scientifique kg 10
à moins de 6 kg dit un baril à l'essai
un nouveau virus si l'année c'est une
épidémie dont l'épidémie chavira odyssée
un nouveau bureau
vous n'avez pas les outils pour deux
pour dissoudre génération identitaire si
vous le faites c'est évidemment pour des
raisons politiques et idéologiques
d'ailleurs ça rentre dans votre agenda
politique puisque d'un côté vous avez
donc vous a fait fait semblant de donner
des gages à la droite en 10 ou
dissolvant baraka city ou le ccf qui
sont des associations islamistes qui ont
pour le coup de réels liens avérés avec
le terrorisme islamiste et donc d'un
autre côté vous voulez donner des gages
à la gauche dont vous avez besoin de cet
électorat donc en dissolvant génération
identitaire parce que bon on vous
reproche pas d'avoir une opinion
vous avez le droit d'avoir une opinion
je la partage pas c'est une chose mais
vous avez le droit de la voir en
revanche l'incitation à la haine
l'incitation aux açores parce qu'en
l'occurrence que j'ai le loire vient de
racisme ça en france c'est rld est
interdit c'est interdit donc quand vous
montez sur le toit d'une mosquée pour
scander les slogans anti ouvriers juste
six mois terminées mais se fait
continuellement le lien en lien directe
des amalgames volontaire entre d'islam
les migrants et le terrorisme ça c'est
interdit fait longtemps que vous suivi
de par mes combats et que je vois déjà
les ratonnades médiatique et numérique
que vous faites sur les réseaux sociaux
vous avez une plate forme qui vous
supportent qui s'appelle twitter ou
quand vous chassez des gens là qu'à voir
ce qui s'est passé une semaine avec le
maire de trappes
qui aujourd'hui par vos collaborateurs
et quand même menacés de mort jamais
j'ai menacé vous il ya six mois quand je
passe ici là je sais que pendant une
semaine savoir le droit ou à démonter
pour aller au bout juste pour aller au
bout oui la 6è quelque chose je pense
que quand on a fait cette émission les
gens ont découvert de manière men stream
parce que c'est le cas de cette émission
ce que vous faisiez et je pense qu'il ya
un côté icare dans votre association
pouvait pas dire devant des gens
notamment un avocat pas vu pas vu pas
pris maintenant on vous a vu on vous
prend et envie de tout se dire mais
qu'est ce qui se passe mais j'en ai
trouvé les éleveurs mais qu'est ce qui
se passe dans ce qu'on vit de savoir les
gens je rentrais dans un magasin le
vendeur m'a dit qu'elle est en boutique
depuis deux ans j'ai trouvé cette pièce
du coup on a vacciné les plus à risque
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on est à soi
on a une moyenne d'âge de 74 ans de gens
vaccinés on est à 37 en espagne parce
qu'ils ont excité tout le monde mais une
fois de plus ça rejoint ce que je disais
il vaut mieux vacciner les gens les plus
fragiles
la stratégie est la bonne pour l'instant
estime que si vous voulez on va avoir en
mars à partir de mars
on va pouvoir voir c'est demain mars
c'est très bientôt elle va pouvoir je
vous dis a plus de saisons sa rivale de
corrélation peut prendre la tronche
chute oui non non il faut avoir une
décorrélation entre un taux d'incidence
qui pourrait augmenter mais de manière
parallèle n'aura pas une augmentation du
taux d'hospitalisation
parce qu'on aura vacciner les plus
fragiles qu'on leur confie nez ou pas
c'est pas notre but c'est quand même le
sait quand même le président de bien sûr
c'est lui que c'est un mec élégant et
c'est c'est un serpent ces cas dans le
livre de la jungle et confiance à brion
que
oui ça m'a un peu stupéfaits d'abord
d'avoir le président au téléphone qu'il
appelait la convivialité et dont je vais
tout simplement dit que maudire est un
pote comme je t'appelle ma poule
j'ai envie de lui dire je le tutoie y
est je le voyais une phrase sur deux
j'ai dit franchement présidence à un
coup d'oeil
mes potes si tu as le site elle
coronavirus qu'est ce tu fais tu fais le
traitement du professeur out et m'a dit
oui oui mais c'était quand cet appel je
lui pardonne on attend cet appel c'est
bah c'était avant qu'il est devant leur
avouer que c'est à la mode quand il
était à la marseille pour voir le
professeur a ou bien ne brille encore et
en avant les études en fait on comprend
tout à fait on peut tout à fait
comprendre sans est un spécialiste et ne
concèdent à la corruption s'est passé
largement les jean-marie le monde qui
cupide kobayashi s'est arrêtée était
cassé ils ont aussi on a dépensé mais
des centaines oui mais c'est un vrai
messie même la mairie est le pays le
plus gros capitalistes de monde même le
tout je veux pas dire ça c'est pas
connexion se fait arrêter qu'est-ce qui
s'est arrêtée tout c'est à dire y'en a
marre et enfin mais tous et à l'économie
c'est arrivé quand même assuré
d'ailleurs ça va détruire et de prix
s'approchant c'est à dire qu'il se tire
une balle dans le pied c'est qu'ils
pensent diriger il serait plus
intelligent que ça dépend avec mesa des
pompes parce que si tu vois par exemple
sud eux regardent un peu de plus haut tu
regardes la démographie du monde
on est sept milliards et demi c'est déjà
le chapeau parce que y'a 3 milliards et
demi qui ne sont que des estomacs à
remplir mais c'est à dire mal écoute
un an et demi maintenant pousser votre
fille a disparu
c'était le 31 juillet 2019 à la saison
vous habitez à evry courcouronnes dans
l'essonne ce matin à 7 heures du matin
il part de chez elles de chez vous donc
pour se rendre à son travail elle est
apprentie esthéticienne dans un institut
de beauté à quelques kilomètres de chez
vous et elle n'y est jamais arrivée tout
un flan la première question comment
quelles étaient vos rapports
ce qu'il ya plein de gens qui vont
demander voilà ce que vous étiez fâché
est ce que vous étiez un très bon
rapport à tout ça se passait bien
quatuor a dit ou un mac les sa maman
chérie donc on était fusionnelle vous
appeler tout le temps aussi au téléphone
tout le temps ça a été exactement tout
le temps on était en contact et du jour
au lendemain
c'est comme si j'ai reçu en fait une vif
donc tu vois
voilà il ya des commentaires à l'été en
embrouille quand vous dites allez c'est
pas du tout le cas donc pas du tout
vraiment y'a juste jamais eu de nom
comme il sait rien il s'est passé quoi
ils ont pris ma plainte en compte pour
disparition inquiétante mais ça s'est
arrêté là le télétravail démété encore
où ils étaient ils étaient présents
jokari c'est comme si le téléphone en
fête a été détruit donc une gamine de 16
ans les pas de son téléphone aussi à
toutes les personnes nées là tiens on va
aller jusqu'au bout et on n'abandonnera
pas notre fille donc si cette personne
nous en tant qu' la relâche donc vous
n'êtes pas là en fait vous êtes persuadé
que c'est que lui avait retourné
quelques pas ma fille ne peut pas couper
les ponts comme ça avec c'est marrant
avec qu'ils étaient renvoyés à bleu vous
rendez compte
et vous savez j'ai beaucoup de remonter
de parents qui ont subi la même chose
c'est sur une maman ce matin qu'ils
m'appellent sa fille a été séquestrée
pendant cinq ans une gamine de 10 ans
qui se promenait dans la rue à qui on a
offert des bonbons qui a été emmenée par
un homme qui a été séquestrée pendant
cinq ans mais c'est donc pas la route
est-ce que vous avez parlé avec jean
marie puis hier est ce que quand il est
revenu il était dans dans quelles
dispositions j'aurrai évidemment en a
parlé c'est mon mari j'habite avec ringo
starr été dissous par décret
en fait il était dans des dispositions
assez bonne parce que il sait qu'il
avait quand même une grande partie des
français qui continuait à penser qu'il
devait s'exprimer
d'accord qu'importe tueur voilà le
contenu mais en tout cas qu'il avait le
droit de le faire
ensuite quelqu'un d' extrêmement
sensible donc il était un petit peu
ébranlé par évidemment les oppositions
des chroniqueurs mais en même temps
c'est pas un enfant non plus donc il
savait qu'il allait peut-être recevoir
quelques coups et puis quand canton et
lui est content dit comme ça tout ce que
certains pensent peut-être tout bas on
s'attend à avoir quelques représailles
ce normal ouais simplement vous me
permettez de dire que c'était fin a
démenti plusieurs médias tv5monde m6 ont
été victimes de piratages combi voci
informatique brigue aussi dans ces cas
là des hackers souvent venus de russie
réclament une rançon dans la fameuse
mené cryptée qui s'appelle le bitcoin
les médias français ont consignes de la
part du gouvernement de ne pas parler à
ne pas payer
donc je ne remet pas du tout en cause de
la version de tf1 je signale simplement
qu'aujourd'hui le gouverneur 3 a lancé
un plan gigantesque c'est vrai un plan
gigantesque les résultats qu'on la dit
aman iman 21 milliards contre le les
cybers attaques et comme par hasard mais
c'est vraiment un hasard c'est sur tf1
et lci que tu avais été révélé
aujourd'hui j'ai 21 ans je la quantité
dont il ya sept ans ouais c'est ça et
donc à 16h allure normale vu que j'étais
derrière
pas d'excès et une personne âgée de 89
ans nous a coupé la route à un stop et
mon père est mort sur le coup et moi
j'ai eu de graves blessures et tout ce à
quoi j'étais avec lui et ses passagers
weiner c'est une histoire
alors vous avez juste un petit peu été
blessées au pouvoir blaise et vous avez
encore des séquelles ou pas non j'ai
plus de séquelles mais j'ai quand même
pas mal eu beaucoup de dommages
corporels comme je suis j'ai passé une
semaine dans le coma près d'ars moins de
souffrance en martyr votre papa mais lui
la souffrance morale à la langue c'est
celui-là avec à la toile il avait 39 ans
il alla or 40 ans 39 ans lui conduisait
et piloter tout bêtement
voilà et qu'il est même quand on a un
très bon pilote voyez en moto et il faut
avoir confiance à ceux qui sont autour
et la personne de 81 devant elle soient
là vous lui avez parlé cette personne
après non non non j'ai peu l'occasion le
problème
[Musique]